انا اسمي ريما من مكارم انا اتخرجت من
كليه هندسه قسم السيارات بقسم نادر شويه
في مصر ويمكن في الدول العربيه برضو كتير
الستات يعني متعرضه للطهاد من كل الناس
اللي بتسوق حواليهم لانه جزء كبير مننا
للامانه مش بيمشي على فوائد صح فاحنا
دائما بنقول الكلمه دي سواقه حريمي هنا في
مصر دارجه يعني
سواء وقته وحش فانا اتضايقت اللي هو احنا
ليه بنحكم بنعمم يعني في بنات بتسوق وحش
فقررت ان انا ليه ما احلش المشكله دي عن
طريق او زي معلومات في فيديو على سواء
حريمي وفي نفس الوقت كمان اعرف البنات
حاجات عن اعطال العربيه ازاي يغيروا
العجله لوحده ازاي لو راحوا لحد ما نصبش
عليهم علامات المرور مش بتتحفظ عشان تعرفي
تقري اي علامه قرور لازم تفهمي معنى
الاشكال الهندسيه اللي جواها علامه المرور
سهله بقى لما درسنا حاجات متخصصه قوي في
العربيات زي تشطيس الاعطال وان انا ازاي
اسمع صوت اعرف احلل سببه ايه اللي جوه
العربيه اصلا ازاي وقعدت ادرس كذا سنه
فحبيت الحوار جدا لانه بقيت اشوف حاجات
المجهوله بالنسبه لي بقيت ممتعه وعمليه
وفيها تشغيل دماغ وفيها تفكير مثلا على
العربيه وفيها مشكله ان في صوت معين او
حاجه معينه بتحصل فنقعد ندرس ونجرب حاجات
ونمشي كده على حاجه او نشوف الاحتمالات
لحد ما نوصل السبب الحقيقي في الموضوع
عامل زي الالغاز كده بالنسبه لي فكان ممتع
جدا جدا
صحيح ان انا بقدمها من خلال سواء حريمي هي
زي ان انا ابقى فاهمه كويس قوي انا بسوق
العربيه دي ازاي القواعد المرور العلامات
اللي بنشوفها بعمل ايه مقفش قدام مثلا
واروح مشغله انتظار واقول انا خلاص وقفت
حد من صحابي عمل كارثه عربيته جابت وش
سلندر لانه زود ميه في وقت غلط طيب تعالي
اقول لك العربيه سخنت منك فجاه تعملي ايه
اكثر حاجه كان نفسي فيها من ورا سواء
حريمي هي كلمه سواقه حريمي تتعكس مصطلح
احفظت يعني بعد ما نمشي كلنا على نفس
الرولز صح ممكن بعده وقت نبقى بنقول على
بنت ولقيتها حريمي الولد
سواقه حلوه يعني وكمان قدام ممكن يبقى زي
مرايه للبنات بتعمل حاجه مميزه في مجال
العربيات
كل ما عملت فكره المحتوى ده في ناس
هاجمتني وكانت بنات مش ولاد يعني الولاد
بالعكس كانوا عملت مره فيديو مثلا وانا
بغير عجله العربيه لما العجله نامت ففي
ناس ايدها ايه
مش عارف ايه وفي ايه اولاد قالوا كده
في بنات كل حاجه هو انا ليه هعمل ده بايدي
ما هو هيروح يعملها لي ويرجع وبتاع
فاتضايقت ان نيجات اللي جات فيه او حاجات
السلبيه اللي كانت من بنات زيي
[موسيقى]